to being with a chance of becoming my
best restaurant all my semi-finalists
will need to be faultless it's got to
take criticism seriously I want to know
if they've corrected the problems I
identified earlier in the competition it
needed more seasoning to help me find
out
I've sent back in my team of secret
diners two of these restaurants will be
leaving the competition immediately
first the risk the chop is my best
Italian Casimir from Bristol brothers
John rain Peter are young and ambitious
and produced delicious food but early in
the competition I discovered at some of
the avant-garde issues were confusing
diners I sent in a new secret diner food
expert Rob Allison to find out the boys
are reined in their wild experimentation
every time these boys create a dish
there's a huge jeopardy olives with star
anis doesn't sound like a perfect
combination but yet again they've pulled
it off next roast lamb sous-vide with
kidneys and pine nuts
[Music]
it was one of the partners but what
about the addition of vacuum-packed
cucumber to the dish
we're taking off much the food at
casimir is magical but some of the
dishes are still misfiring
it sounds really negative and it sounds
like yeah we could be possibly going
home there's that's the way it looks
next to face the video evidence is
Chinese winner you and you from
Blackburn and Lancashire father Charlie
Lee's son head chef Victor were
overjoyed to win their heat Junior
Oh
but I had concerns that were heavily
overstaffed beauty pageants waitress in
there Blackburn's next top model it's an
issue that needs to be addressed why
Alaska
[Music]
the problem is when you get a lot of
stuff and the restaurants not very busy
it's more interesting kind of standard
owner gossip and actually looking after
the customers with you knew that was my
one big concern was appointed all those
staff when they're not looking after
customers seems to be a different person
that comes I don't know who's
responsible for chopsticks and somebody
is responsible for clearing wait when we
just our waiter it's not the way to have
a warm service you don't make customers
feel relaxed every time something hits
the table it's a new waitress I'm
looking for the best restaurant on the
daily basis with the best food in the
best service and I want to see
restaurants get better despite the
setback I'm pleased to see you and you
are still serving a wonderful food
that's a fear that we start a business
in crunchy and the batter's actually
really lied thanks really close that's a
real strong element with you and you
they are constantly pushing the
boundaries out and they're trying to
reinvent Chinese cuisine but with her
21st century approach us Nam gym was my
champion Thai from some Andrews in
Scotland it's a great restaurant but my
undercover cameras discovered really
surprising problems with service
is there what ranks as about the most
aggressive service I've ever seen in my
life with my new secret diner get better
treatment
you know the beef banana Cory you don't
do a lot of chicken or inversion great
flexibility from the dining room staff
um she doin the chicken will be curry
she wanted prawns and so they did it it
wasn't even on the menu the services
miles better what about the food when I
went there I discovered that some of the
dishes were slow in leaving the kitchen
it's not the sauce isn't hot and the the
rice isn't very warm I they should be
hot when it comes to a table damn food
not piping hot it was one of the concern
their food hangs on the hot plate they
shouldn't sit there as it sits there the
goodness is disappearing but more
importantly the food's getting cold
my best Spanish Pinot is the final
restaurant astaire elimination in the
face they barely put a foot wrong in
their heat
head chef Nevers produces authentic
Spanish food has impressed everyone
my undercover critic Simon Davis is
there to save they've kept their
standards up oh shut the [ __ ] up yeah
incredible my see gudinas blown away but
listen to the atmosphere in the
background
yeah it's buzzing and you can't buy the
atmosphere really good start but Annie's
main course my secret diner detects
signs of over seasoning
[Applause]
I'm the first bit of negative feedback
my secret Donna slightly clumsy on the
seasoning or shame I told all four
restaurants to expect my core
they know that I'm looking for
perfection but only two will survive
this stage it's the moment of truth I am
nervous whether we've done enough I
can't I can't answer that let's hope so
may I speak to Sam please how are you
Sam I'm very well that you know you yeah
not bad thanks not bad
hi it is yes nervous yeah unfortunately
the couple of dishes were slightly
heavy-handed with the seasoning oh I
want to see westerns get better and
climb across this competition and you
and you
is not going to the next stage of this
competition all right
sorry we're doing it for best
stuff in is really my area and him I
think we lost lost it to go through to
the next round because of that just I
think what you probably do sorry
Victoria you only do your best now yeah
Sam I'm sorry
unfortunately I have to eliminate two
restaurants from this competition it's
about to get even harder for fee no
because you're through to the next page
on this competition congratulations
[Applause]
I was good I mean my necks is shaking
now so it's a good sign it's good time
one restaurant is out and one has
survived my sudden death elimination now
I have to make one more very tough call
just very nervous I think you won't be
white mind if you was actually nervous
about the situation to go out at this
stage would be very upset it's the first
semi-final of my nationwide arrest in a
competition
Spanish heat winners Fino have survived
my secret dining elimination now it's
down to my best Thai Nam gym and my top
Italian casimir one of them is about to
be knocked out
yes it is hello Gordon unfortunately I
have to eliminate direction of this
competition you know this competition is
about searching for the best restaurant
and I fell in love with knowledge in
from the first when I walked in there
whatever happens after this phone call
you've got to continue phenom Jim it's
been an amazing journey today
[Music]
is where it comes on end Jesus don't
listen I'm very very proud yeah yes the
competition is getting harder and
Catherine Mia
congratulations one of the team I were
able to me the more it sinks in yet
before fantastic and yeah it's just
brilliant to feel appreciated and given
a chance to keep girl
so two brilliant wrestlers remain in the
first semi-final
and I'm gonna pitch them both in a
head-to-head battle first I have a
surprise in store
I'm about to drop in unexpectedly from
meal on a manga family-run Italian
restaurant Casimir from Bristol and
modern Spanish tapas restaurant FINA
from London to help me decide who will
make it to the final I've enlisted two
trusted lieutenants for a second opinion
on strengths and weaknesses of these two
restaurants Angela Hartnett one of the
most successful British chefs of the
last 15 years service and Simon Davis
one of the my secret diners an expert in
putting restaurants through their paces
they know the restaurant business inside
a house I trust their opinions
implicitly
[Music]
the first time I visited Casimir I found
their cooking to be new and exciting but
I discovered young chef John ray and
Peter sometimes push things too far and
they're experimental dishes can be hit
and miss if you're trying to be
avant-garde you've got to go with your
customers you've got to take every
customer forward their parents Susan and
Paco sang their life savings into the
restaurant but it says sons who caught
all the shots and cook exactly what they
want whether the customer likes it or
not I want to find out what Angela and
Symon think so we've caught them on the
whole hi guys how you both do you expect
before to senior officer thank you
Casimir are fully booked expectations
are high for top-notch food and service
[Music]
[Music]
which I don't normally do I think that's
just nerves
I know Kissimmee will be trying to
impress me but in a great restaurant
everyone should get special treatments
so fast my personal assistant and a
partner to dine here as well anonymously
I'll find out what they think later in
this restaurant
diners literally get what they're given
kazimierz among guard nine-course
tasting menu for our fish course we're
having salmon cooked sous-vide in a
water bath with cauliflower puree and a
lemon emulsion that's picturesque that
is ravishing Ashley beautifully
presented plates of food delicious
brilliant they haven't claimed finesse
next what the menu refers to as a
traditional risotto but true to form the
boys have given it their unique twist
using barley instead of rice and is
topped with cold yogurt not parmesan
I mean traditional is the wrong word you
can't call that a traditional result the
cold and the hot sensation I found it
just chilled the whole dish down for me
it's very sweet again yeah thank you
mother
thank you you can't win everything you
know and that's it it's a tasting menu
there's certain dishes and people were
in like hopefully they're like all of
them and and some more than others but I
said really next course is lamb yet
another dish cooked in a water bath you
know a spa it'll have a spa bath it's
going for a bath
I'm a huge fan of the sous-vide method
but the real skill is understanding
which dishes it suits the guys also
correct me if I'm wrong
that's where sous-vide cooking that
falls down there just occurred that
really well doesn't taste it very much
boiled lamb chew as opposed to you know
a cannon that wants that sort of nutty
buttery slightly gamey flavor yeah
damn what a shame finally it's time for
dessert an unusual take on a traditional
Italian pudding that starts with an
introduction from the boys our earliest
memory of good Italian cooking was the
dessert tiramisu given to us by our
Father and takeaway Kyle to us you know
what the best bit here it says sometimes
the best really is that simple
well let's see the way people make
batteries
too much alcohol that's too sweet you've
gotta take a expresso that is
exceptionally good he's good we've
tasted some outstanding cuisine but some
dishes have fallen short
technically I'm they're in a league of
their own yeah Stella really stellar and
yeah you know really the top of that
tree but they need to cook for the
punter yeah at the moment they're
cooking for themselves they're cooking
for their parents and they're cooking
for their hero chefs it's always
difficult with a family restaurant but
here more than anywhere else
Chef John ray and Peter need a strong
guiding hand and their parents aren't
providing it I don't think they give him
the feedback you can't as a parent you
can't be that brutal meaning you can't
be a manager and slap it down and no one
likes this time to call the family
together for a debrief here's what we
saw highs and lows technically brilliant
without shadow of doubt but you need to
rein it in you need to rein it in and
understand it from a customer's point of
view not your ambition because when the
customers are happy you're happy you're
in business customers are the power
today and for me the secret behind any
good experience is how every else feels
in that dining room and there's a second
surprise tonight because there's someone
in that dining room that means a lot to
me because she organizes my life
Jennifer please darling and Michael how
was it feel very special and we really
enjoyed our evening and we thought the
chefs or ingenious and talented and I
think at the end the tiramisu wonderful
turnout - really really cute lovely
later my undercover diners enjoyed their
meal but I'm still concerned over Susan
and Paco have they got it in them to run
this restaurant with a firm hand
I love my mom to dance a bit some said
that before you know me and P there's no
question about it
we're ambitious as hell we want to be in
the same Vegas water Ramsey on Angela
Hana one day we'd like to think we
almost there but this makes me more
determined when a politician will murmur
as an overall-experience going out for
dinner yeah it was it was it was good
but I can't be great I have just slow
down and rein it in a bit if they can
control their ambition and focus on
their customers they'll surprise
themselves
[Music]
next it's time to surprise Fino
we can't afford to do war favors is give
them an easy ride turn the place upside
down really put them under pressure
yeah
so far this hugely successful Spanish
tapas restaurant has powered through
this competition as we turned up
unannounced I hope they haven't let
their high standards slip how are you
well good to see you
like most lunchtime diners we want to be
in and out in just one hour
HFD Aversa known as salmon Eddy will
have to produce a perfect meal with
speed and efficiency it's gonna be busy
services fully booked so it's gonna be
quite a sight then we're gonna dance in
the kitchen today we're here for a lunch
and we want to be treated like a normal
customer and she would do it which makes
the best thing in for us is to Eddie
Knight to leave you in the hands of one
of our noble waitresses and they break
up take me for them unknown Tofino my PA
jennifer is also dining here and once
again she'll offer a secret perspective
on the restaurants performance
[Music]
spit page one one of the first dishes to
arrive is cheap erroneous deep-fried
baby squid good but I tell you what
there is a way we'd have the salt out
quite a lot of salt over seasoning is
once again a problem I'm just keen to
get to the root of the issue with the
physic their seasoning but what was I
like to have on TV mr. Lomax
who's there any one thing is the chip
really because of its sources every dish
that goes up on the park sheepish extra
salt pepper and I said don't they finish
it off themselves cheers oh no but I had
a bit more about placing it just makes
sense you gotta trust you all Ches yes
we told the restaurant that we're on an
hour's deadline but the main still take
40 minutes to arrive just just dip your
finger as cold
as phrasing on mission be called but the
problem with the pork belly is not just
the temperature so part of it far too
many other it's really overpowering it's
like going to the dentist with
anesthetic for their finest hour now it
for that one we have to leave in just
five minutes and still no one's taken
out deserve orders we're running very
tight of time could you recommend
something quick free desserts and what
would you we're out of time
we have to go that's why I asked me to
choose sweet quick desserts no difficult
two seconds please
I'd like the bill and like salmon Eddie
please thank you so much damn that's a
shame
[Music]
I have to be honest I'm disappointed
because it's nowhere near as good as it
was last time round there's a strand of
over seasoning food that is being cooked
by the brigade and re seasoned by the
chef before it goes what I'm more
nervous about is the sloppy service I
think what's interesting is look we'll
keep looking around the room is the
tables who obviously weren't trying to
test her to test out the service you
know cousin I've seen Maya nice was good
and the quality the food was good
Eddy's bold claim is about to be put to
the test by my PA Jennifer how was lunch
we actually mixed feedback we felt that
the Welcome needed work the staff seemed
preoccupied at the beginning and we felt
a little abandoned I thought that the
stuffed courgette blur with the goats
cheese was a triumph it looked pretty
acerbic a suit and a taste with divine
however towards the ends when the
restaurant became extremely busy
unfortunately the service tailed off and
we began to feel neglected and in fact
our team coffee order was awesome
we've said before we like to be the best
we like to win and obviously it's not a
great day when when it goes wrong carpet
something being taken out from under our
feet and that's not a good feeling my
last experience here was near flawless
and it was almost on the verge of
perfection that was embarrassing
great restaurants need to be flexible
and constantly involved to survive
through these difficult times so I want
my semi-finalists Casimir and FINA to
really prove to me they can create
something extraordinary against the logs
they both now face one grueling test for
placing the final a challenge like I've
never ever experienced before in just 12
hours they must turn this bear shell
into a thrilling vibrant pop-up
restaurant open for one night only I
want to see if my two semi-finalists can
create an amazing one-off dining
experience with a tight budget and a
deadline it's daybreak and I've called
both FINA or Casimir to meet me here in
Islington North London good morning it's
early right and you're probably thinking
what in the hell am I doing here and
let's be honest
it doesn't look great lemmas does it for
bare walls bleach yeah today you go to
transform this boring somewhat cold
shell into the most amazing unique
pop-up restaurants forget your
restaurants create something magical
good luck
what with restaurants are one of the
hottest trends in the food world they
spring up in unexpected locations cause
a big storm and then disappear overnight
as the cash both restaurants will have a
2,000 pound budget to split between
front of house for decor and the chef's
for ingredients
let's take 600 because I don't want to
be in the [ __ ] good luck guys - op Annie
no sir they've only got until 7 p.m. to
trade their restaurant from scratch for
up to 50 hungry diners who will expect
nothing but the best
so anything we have to cook we have to
do you have to prepare probably a really
new challenge
I'm taking the chef's to the markets and
I'll be really fascinating to see how
this amazing produce gets their creative
juices flowing and they'll have to
really think on their feet and adapt
their menus based on what they find
first up the butcher's guinea fowl that
brace what's going through your mind cuz
you've got to start coming up main
course one of them what is gonna be okay
you guys yeah I've got to get that
locked down here we don't think about
this for the next five goddammit sucky
throughout this competition
Kassem may have reduced some amazing
food but some of it has been so
experimental it has missed the mark will
they be tempted to show up tonight
or will they rein in for their diners
[Music]
auction but Peter and John Ray are
tempted by real rolls-royce ingredients
beef they'd love to cook it sous-vide
with a frog our parfait served with
popcorn there's not a water bath this
side you can cook without a [ __ ]
water bath let's get that oh yeah quite
easy so you could have come out of that
frame for a minute and you go back to
the beginning
I want these boys to forget some of
their wild experimentation tonight can
they cook something simple
with no frills well these are the early
for yeah we're gonna go for the really
poor plus cleaners head chef Nevers
cooks fantastic Spanish tapas and pork
features heavily on their menu but I
want to see if you can go one step
further and do something extraordinary
for this one night only
you're a compliment for carne yeah and
he did is the main course starts or he's
gonna be awesome mangoes cuz there are
the cuts you've got the most amazing
loin I know I know but people love belly
pork I love it you know Christmas dinner
so I just hopefully hopefully I'll get
it right
so fourteen of those decision made pork
belly a great cheap car to do but John
rain Peter still can't decide between
flashy beef or simple pork
[Music]
this year and time is running out fast
hopefully boosted is accurate for it to
change our change the co2 injuries yeah
we trigger the change quarter we go back
so casimiro routes go to port it's
cheaper it's got great flavor we have to
work it harder was working flavors work
my planet secure it and then a bit so
sorry the change might know before wears
it thoughtfully ever since i sir
let's go way too soon
I'm surprised Casimir have gone for pork
too but I've chosen a prime cut as well
as a belly and I'll be fast agency what
both restaurants do with it one night
only let's see what they've given us a
successful Russian isn't just about
fabulous food the front of how teams
must race against the clock to bring
their pop-up restaurants to life cheap
very nicely they're working to a tight
budget and I want to see how creative
they can be I personally think we ought
to go no cloth I think some wouldn't
take me semmen Eddie helped by one of
their managers Koshka are going for a
simple Spanish feel I mean that's not
bad
helped by the restaurant manager an
Susan and Paco are downstairs trying to
choose crockery the boys will like there
are real bargains to be had at 15 pence
a plate but they're scared it won't meet
the boys high expectations I'm just
worried we're not gonna get it all done
[Music]
across London I'm taking the chef to
another of my favourite markets for fish
right now this is a dream come true for
any chef because this project is
incredible choice too much choice is
trying to get the right device fish
doesn't get any better than this nervous
he's drawn to the delicious mackerel and
wild sea bass it spread on the wild sea
bass is an irresistible ingredient for
the young chefs from casa mia to good in
Chelsea
Paco's Susan and Anne have decided to
search for planes in a department store
but time is tight and they'll have just
40 minutes to get everything they need
excuse me could you tell me how much
each their five pound each oh my god do
you do anything cheaper than these
resister cheapest here the plates start
from two pounds each but Susan could
have got similar back up base for just
15 pence so if we could have 35 of these
35 of these 35 of those it's a costly
decision spending more money on plates
here means they'll have less to spend on
the look of the restaurant
okay let me think let me think should we
just put some make candles around we
need some flowers is well we need to get
we've got no money
we're in their embrace [ __ ] here we're
gonna put on the tables come on guys
we're wasted what we're gonna put on the
tone got their choice okay say we can
have different colored ones I know the
boys are gonna hate it but they're
cheaper and we need to have some ready
more that's five of eight that's four
hundred it's okay it's okay it's okay so
all right cool this is no it'll be a
stress out but they'll go to compromise
sweat and tears isn't come on we're just
tired and stressed and I'm just worried
about this evening
yeah they may not be the best decoration
and the best-looking restaurant in the
world but the service and the food are
gonna be yeah ex Sardinia
okay so yeah I think focus on that okay
Susie its midday just seven hours left
for the team's create their pop-up
restaurants back at base the taking the
delivery of their furniture and crockery
nicely there looks like a Japanese
restaurant Oh Paco we've had it now
Susan's out of depth they need to
understand the pop-up is a
one-night-only mega experience and this
is it
showoff create those fireworks because
that's what's going to make your
restaurant win this competition upstairs
I get the sense that posh boys Sam and
Eddie haven't been to Ikea before and
didn't realize that they're eight
natural wood tables comes flat-pack set
115 minutes
let's go take us an hour which is timing
I probably doing something else and also
this is all everyone has
[Music]
downstairs pack on Susanna working on
the finishing touches I was expecting
this morning all why is this gonna even
look like a dining room but we're
getting there slowly with no time to
spare
someone Eddie finally master flat packed
a nice restaurant but it still captures
what we are good job and pleased with
what we double there I'm back I can't
believe that we've actually made this
horrible we're women looking so where
are you good mother
[Music]
[Applause]
you know over there just we are there
some you know it's been it's been a
close run thing this afternoon but we're
sorted
[Music]
it's seven o'clock queues of hungry
diners wait to be seated
the small allows it's great from scratch
- stunning restaurants yeah for bare
walls - empty shells one kitchen
the pressures on guys and in three hours
time one Russians leaving this
competition and one restaurant is going
through to the final
they have just three hours to impressed
with a thrilling one-off dining
experience waiting too long and that
experience should start as soon as
people walk in tomato mozzarella
hey customer a restaurant check on tape
you got the first order in five minutes
Susan you feeling okay Wow and she's
smiling nice one table one all right
want to see what sorta I have to say I'm
impressed I've had my doubts where the
Mum Susan can run a restaurant with a
firm hand but tonight she seems
determined to prove me wrong
they've come together at the right time
and we know it's not how you sighs how
you finish but great [ __ ] star come
on keep this under an L in Russian
Casimir are already busy taking orders
leaving FINA playing catch-up
the mecca we'll start with thank you
Shakur but as their purse orders reach
the kitchen already there's a problem
it's the semi-finals of my nationwide
restaurant competition and it's Spain
versus Italy we know from London and
castamere from Bristol they've created
pop-up restaurant from scratch and the
end of tonight's service of decide who
goes through to the final great [ __ ]
star
but binos kitchen has ground to a halt
head chef Nieves can't decipher salmon
Eddie's handwritten checks and they're
seen as gelled as they should be the
casa mia boys have created two amazingly
simple starters on their menu a
delicious fresh tomato jam salad with
mozzarella dusted in parmesan guys I
need you here like you're [ __ ]
hanging off a cliff chatting free life
service come on fantastic food but
served in a soup bowl first tasting
foods
ladies their second starter is a rustic
Paris mushroom soup whatever what was
that that is stable quite so you got
more Super than the oven there same
table I have to be the exact same size
I'm watching everything
[Music]
and that was the best thing you ever
tasted but it's not to everyone's liking
just give me two seconds I'll be
straight back okay
in the past I found doting mom Susan
usually leaves to her son's defense on
any criticism of their food but tonight
is great to see her treat her sons like
chefs not children just say yes right
away two minutes ago
I love Fino Spanish tan few starters
stuck in and baby beetroot salad with
walnuts and Stilton and a spectacular
mackerel dish with grapes and apple
salad
[Music]
great went really well these dishes are
free no at their best but under this
intense pressure never else needs to
make sure every plate is perfect girls a
little bit of feedback one Taylor just
over hearing them a little bit salt in
this helmet on the start of the macro
one table so one hour in three no I've
fallen behind the Goths are really [ __ ]
start not only that but foods coming
back and the mackerel is salty which is
a common thread across we know we would
pick up the speed pick up the gear pick
up the standards he knows but this will
get better on to the mains and nervous
his plan is not the diner socks off with
the wonderful flavors of a Fino classic
belly of pork with red wine sauce
fantastic she's also cooking an amazing
wild sea bass with squid wrapped in
smoked pancetta it's almost perfect but
with little else but fish on the plate a
worry relax balance and need some
garnish
well they don't yes we know available
this is Romania I know we don't have
them in the menu nervous what I'm trying
to do to make her happy she wants
potatoes can we do it yes if we can do
them chef please and he'll sort out as a
situation okay my one concern with the
best was no starch on there the rich
sauce the squid it needs a stock Joey
needs something along those lines but we
can bought the Taylor's it takes six or
seven modes and love the way Pinot do
everything they can to please their
customers to one port you said two
minutes two minutes ago there'd be about
point four minutes SharePoint minutes
let's just do what I've got any other
back in the kitchen
John rain Peter also serving pork but a
mixing belly with prime cup Phillip top
with italian garnishes so disgusting me
up
[Music]
meanwhile sweet the boys are also
creating a fantastic Italian sea bass
with cannellini beans I love it because
it's so simple
no wild avant-garde frills for this dish
I had the sea bass for my main course
this skin was crispy this the fish was
cooked perfectly
Table one main horseback said that was
the best piece of fish she's ever had in
her life
FINA finishing with a classic Spanish
dessert Santiago tart put this poplar
sweet be their winning touch no this is
me again they're good-looking one for
their dessert
John ray and Peter are serving a modern
Italian take on apple crumble with
almond in pews custard but they've added
a twist that's leaving some of my diners
confused the apples mother might
lukewarm but the rest of it is very cold
[Music]
slightly warm because it too hot the
flavor can be affected kazimierz apple
crumble is meant to be eaten warm but is
leaving some customers cold 10 p.m. and
service is over tonight the diner's
decided how much to pay they loved both
restaurants so the takings were equal
but this challenge wasn't simply about
money
well done make sure a tough 12 hours
there was a battle against time and
pressure to create a thrilling dining
experience for one night only this
evening the kitchen have put their heart
and soul into it and I just think we're
gonna win I mean I believe we're at the
edge today to be in the final of
Ramsay's best restaurant would be a
culmination of you know kind of a lot of
hard work it'd be amazing would be
absolutely fantastic I'm so happy
because both questions seriously push
the boat out and the hard part for me
right now is that I have to make a
decision between those two restaurants
[Music]
this has been one of the toughest
challenges I've ever set
there are times but I honestly didn't
think both restaurants were going to
make it
and I started to panic
and as the clock ticked away the
restaurants just started emerging coming
individual restaurants with identity
character the atmosphere in both
restaurants amazing the food stunning
and on the back of the last three hours
we've made it incredibly difficult for
me to decide on which restaurants go
through to the final that's what a
pop-up restaurant is all about a one-off
one night only unique experience
and on the back of that performance it's
such a close call based on everything
I've seen these guys deftly understand
flavors
[Music]
everything I tasted the proper Spanish
dish and picturesque beautifully
presented plate of food
everything I've listened to cast me a
restaurant check on table for price one
moment to make her happy she wants
potatoes can we do it yes if we can do
them chef please the restaurant going
through to the final
[Music]
this
just a man yes yes
[Music]
well done thank you well done you can
smoke okay well done well done
[Music]
Fozzy was a new new challenge so it was
really tough obviously disappointed but
I mean the guys they are amazing just a
mere are in the final because they
understood for the first time in this
competition what customers want John
rain Peter dropped the frills and they
delivered I think they're amazing
we've got two little geniuses but my
yacht can they cook [ __ ] impressive